men chuckle Jaden Hana himejima give me
that you hadn't reported in Google
cartoonish exam Tarawa meter isn't until
6:00 and terawatt me he isn't a joke
here he sunk this at all to reverse well
he isn't a joke here
he sank this at all to reverse service
ibrehem G give me I'm innocent kid you
gotta keep pills on terra firma de can
Equis local or tell su money comes in
you saw you get compared a lot to Bruce
Lee right because the way you move them
because the way do certain things to the
average person is tough to believe so
woman you didn't solve one murder it's
only to be untouchable Daniel boomer all
took it personally on that cutting table
see how painful is it to get hit by the
shoulder I told them as even the
conditions were fatal you can kill
somebody
what's your hug each on their garage
sure got to sanctimonious color is that
even real like guys amazing guy kind of
make me feel like kind of regrets do you
fear anything no nothing
yeah if you were to get into MMA today
do you think you could Hank and fight
with some of the other guys this is
gonna hurt typically punch me once I
want to see what it feels good punch ya
wanna feel oh wow did you know it's
crazy you feel the bone did you ever
think you will make it take sweet
victory I know this life
yeah why would you bet on Goliath but we
got red tape value Kaman given values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we can evaluate this honey run homie
look what I become I'm the one
[Music]
so my guest today is a world-renowned
martial artist probably has a couple
billion views on YouTube and Facebook
combined
he also somebody that studies a form of
philosophy combination of eastern and
western which we'll talk about any
happens to be an entrepreneur we flew
him out here all the way from South
Korea he is here with his translator but
he also speaks English so sometimes
he'll be answering if he doesn't his
translator will also be answering for us
having said that DK you thank you for
being again somebody appreciates you for
coming out thank you for also coming out
no problem
so uh so uh some curious you know how
did you get into martial arts how did
you get into who you are today again we
know you from the videos that we've seen
it's intense some of the stuff that you
do but how did DK you he's raw martial
artists he says mental educator and also
businessman entrepreneur so what what
happened and that's great but what
happened for you like what was the
turning point and how did you get
introduced to martial arts so italiano
passion doing it - yeah it's a - yeah
it's a sudden day
some care package about $10 a Samhita
content each a horrible chica come
tradition and a community ro
psychoanalytic italian heceta clockwise
Oh Tito
Musel girl or man OMG Ginga Jung
sang-soo Ohio cool Tony moly Kennesaw
Chris engineering go short on kanji by
mechanic on English again Simon ought to
keep a casinos you could take a dollar
sale Chris oku euro or st. John Belushi
English didn't go so young boy okay cool
cuz I'm a shame Charaka mgq episode Toby
Sheeran and Pongo baroque wanna return
Camilla so he first started this journey
in 1998 1989 he got diagnosed with a
tumor kind of really near his brain like
the bridge of his nose and a doctor so
now even we had three months to live up
in years old
at 10 years old so they were and the
tech not the medical technology wasn't
that great in South Korea back then so
you know they
I thought he was gonna die in three
months but what happened was that his
grandfather was a police officer and he
trained extensively in martial arts
meditation his grandfather his
grandfather did and he recommended that
if you have the will to survive and
train these methods I think you might be
able to beat it and that's exactly what
happened he was able to beat the illness
and from then on he kind of had an
epiphany you know the will to survive is
greater than anything and he started
seeing as a way of life and combining
you know movement philosophies that he's
been learning and basically creating
warfare combat system WCS is his
business pretty much and in present day
and that would be his art right if is
that a form of art the WCS system so
yeah and it's it's a form of art
philosophy mental training everything
that's been combined together okay WCS
yes and your grandfather what form of
art that he practice what was he
practicing uh some Taiwanese society in
Scenario domain means enjoy the casino
mentor training world
odorous deposit on vinyasa Mita so his
grandfather had various masters when it
comes to training the mind like
meditations and stuff but you know he
was a police officer so the martial arts
part was very you know practical okay
it's a direction so it wasn't a high
level practice practitioner him so he
wasn't he just practice a little bit
with some basic martial arts pretty much
okay yeah but more philosophy more
somebody that was how to meditate how to
calm yourself down how to control your
emotions more an expert in that area
right exactly okay that's good to know
so so he's doing that your grandfather's
not somebody that's in it as much as you
get into it
what's next steps for you to become who
you are like what do you start studying
who did you look at was there any kind
of inspiration that you had he said I
like the way he is and I kind of want to
follow his footsteps how did that happen
it's hung in there we got the euros and
Richie Madden we market we're more
mature and a patron gotten mugged a cool
could imagine
MGK more poaching some baby directors
how much we're not out on a magic act in
San Diego could church Hongzhang
incidentally conjecting a conditional
equation all-new keynote Anthony
Calvillo Lovins under context new
keynesian raccoon and their cool
Michigan cocoons haven't 300 hang it's a
checkered Lugano Coventry Michigan don't
get them with you Christie Cruz rm3 a
ton Mary honey I tell us all christened
didn't do it alleged and the crew is
equally the young quad is a kilometer in
the tomb grace honor putana Jesus na
socati na toes under come great Qin mo
Chiu Cunha or even animation all the way
oMG him your robot aliens are under
capturing together at a younger age so
it's not just martial artists he would
look at everybody who's at the top of
their game
you know soccer Ronaldo Messi boxing
Mayweather you know Muhammad Ali and
pretty much all all across the board
different types of disciplines he would
look at it and the way he perceived it
is that those people have something
going on in their consciousness they
have risen to the place where it's you
know completely untouchable by others
and he was really attracted to that and
start studying their lives and their
methods basically in South Korea
so let me ask you if I do my math right
in 1998 10 years old is it fair to say
he you're 31 years old he's at 31 or 32
he's 40 he's 40 so in 1998 10 years old
or 1989 1980 Oh 1989 1990 okay sorry
okay you look like you're 25 years old
it's a complete different story I look
like I'm 50 but you look like you're 25
years old so okay so you're 40 years old
right now is that fair I just kind of
want to put it together okay so that's
great that you're studying Ronaldo Messi
all these guys but at 10 years old
Ronaldo Messi aren't yet or an aldohn
Messi what I'm trying to find out is
when you were at 10 who did you start
studying I know that there was a general
that you were you admired our general
you
you from the Chinese dynasty right and
but but was there anybody else most
people that watch you Americans who
don't know you because most people don't
know who you are they just kind of seen
some of your videos you kind of you get
compared a lot to Bruce Lee right a lot
of times you they say oh he's like the
modern-day Bruce Lee because the way you
move him because the way do certain
things did you kind of watch what he did
did you kind of study some other stuffs
who were some of the guys they studied
specifically when it comes down to
martial arts not the philosophy because
we're gonna get that here in a moment
it's specifically on the way you fight
you do nice a good chunk Unni don't they
cuz I mean hold him sorry so you can
take me on Sanjay how many we are
the Kaurava teaching google+ combined
essay philosophy no boo move on to the
combine in his Oh cuz are they concern I
mean can they keep putting six sangtae's
a Hanan movement will camera on it Joe
the coup Thawra me or you really change
I heard about that it's cool cuz I mean
check-in I don't go tell put me on saw
gingka you check out how long ago -
Pataki the Scimitar single-channel today
on you gotta go to me chinga you
children told me Sheikh Yassin negative
the sitter hang with you so he didn't
really know about birthday when he was
yes you didn't know Bruce yes I know Wow
in South Korea you don't overstay okay
you were saying and like you mentioned
earlier his grandfather actually
introduced him to the general the
Chinese general you day you and he
started looking up his work you know his
books and that's where he kind of
started with that whole you know the
mind and body is one philosophy the the
general the general yeah and he you know
he was a he was affiliated with the
Shaolin Temple back then yes you know he
taught you know thousands of people and
he's considered one of the greatest
generals of his time yeah I won and
actually looked him up he's from 1503 to
1579 I think something like that so it's
it's a it's a long time ago and they
don't even know where his birthday is
what day he was born right and and he
had he was many different things he was
a mathematician he was you know
and artist yet all these other
philosophies and politics is is he and
China viewed as a like if you were to
tell us who he is is he a Alexander
level type of person like you know what
I'm saying is he known as an Alexander
the Great type of a general type of guy
or how do you how do how does how do you
look at him how do you view him yes of
course basura chinguga an ambassador at
Anzio most recent they could happen I
meet you happen sir I mean there
chikubi something crooked supermoon okay
you know so back in the day not anymore
apparently but he was considered like
Aleksandar degrades because he's the one
that combined all the different types of
martial arts there was you know
prevalent back in the day and created
this new form that was more efficient
and practical basically he made it
practical and got it and and so you at
10 years old you don't know Bruce Lee
how old were you the first time you
heard about Bruce Lee you should tear my
trombone naked a marathon awesome you
don't know about Bruce Lee to mid-20s
yes
that's intense to say that because you
move just like him no I'm telling you
you know how you watch Kobe and you put
Jordan next to each other you kind of
see similar movements when you when you
see some of the ways you do with certain
things that's very similar so so who did
you watch like because you're 40 years
old which means in South Korea where are
you getting your content from like what
are you watching is it videos is it
movies is it books you're reading what
are you watching - get your style of
fighting how do you learn the moves well
there there really wasn't anybody that
he was looking at in the media that you
know sparked that's anybody locally that
he went and watched because because I
almost feel like you know because if
that's not the case then what you're
trying to say is it came out spiritually
out of him right it's almost like a
spiritual thing you're doing but for
something like this that's a skill some
of the stuff that's skilled you got to
kind of watch somebody to do it right
who was the person that did he train
somewhere locally did he go to a certain
master locally was there anybody like
that or no
the hunger get demanding 2003 so cool
the equivalent ago more nya fauna and in
most Akina and motion you know she don't
hit Jima take out the table Ice King
gonna test this rule or turn get me some
graboid diamond or take a look in
Michigan on with the buoy run cousin or
changing the tyrosine your angle gamma
retires in degree mom do Goku would kind
of tie restraining order Arabian and
there it was a boxing boxing buckaroo
hot on autumn or someone hadn't got a
hot iron angry the createrra katakana so
what means you can take cookie Batarang
good chromosome mmm no I guess Oh chucka
guys no honey no yeah mmm so he had
various teachers when he was learning he
says probably more than 10 but he
arrived here by kind of like realizing
on it on its own pretty much so he this
is his stuff so there were you know you
know preludes to all of this and he had
various masters at taught him you know
boxing knife fighting street fighting
everything and up to meditation but the
way he arrived here is because he had
his own epiphany and he was really good
at it from the start and he was kind of
well known within the community while he
was young and he was young so he went
out and just fought and fought and
fought industry it was more streets yeah
oh got into a bunch of knife fights he
fought more than one person at a time so
he has scars on his body like knifes
cars pretty much he's got a knife scars
all over his body
yeah yeah got it so he got in he got in
the mix he started fighting and then
internally you know because he he
doesn't take any credit away from any
art he's respectful of every art out
there and what they do he doesn't say
this is better than the other one you
know judo is better than Tai Chi or Tai
Chi's better than karate or karate is
better than talk one he doesn't he
doesn't do anything like that to say
what's better what's not but you know
when you when you go back and you're
looking at that moment
your practice and martial arts what
what's he getting into tourneys was he
doing professional fighting was he
getting into like you know how on us we
have MMA right now we have boxing right
now did he get into any kind of
professional fighting the ordinal
tornado today yeah you're talking about
the Jaeger house from gay oh don't come
get on a professional fight on our box
on I don't give a damn betta so first of
all he wants to say you know he respects
all the many fighters all the pro
fighters but they will not a pants like
we only take out one on the panel thing
and then there take a look at think of
painful one cool pro fighter did I pass
out to the sale so you know all the Pro
fighters MMA fighters have their own way
and he has his own and that's just
didn't really cross pass
I just didn't cross paths got it going
back to the general going back to the
generator with AMA you tell about he
studied shaolin monastery right and in
the Shaolin master monastery talk about
to know Shaolin you must know the 18
Shaolin disciples what is that for
somebody that doesn't know what that
means
probably okay okay yeah I'm breathing
down girl yeah so he doesn't really know
because again I'm trying to see you know
I'm reading a book I think it's called
range I just finished a book range and I
think it's range where he talks about in
the book the story of Pete's amperes and
the story of another tennis player who
becomes the best right we're not Pete
Sampras Roger Federer Roger Federer
wasn't from a family that from the
beginning they made him play tennis
rajat kind of accidentally became a
tennis player and then he becomes the
best right versus on the other hand they
choose an example I think it was Agassi
or another kid that from a young age
parents put a lot of money into this guy
being a tennis player and it was very
regimented to become a tennis player and
Roger Federer accidentally ends up
becoming who he is today and the other
one does as well but he took a complete
different route same as would music
there's a lot of musician you think
about back in the days Beethoven Mozart
that they didn't have a teacher they
didn't have somebody that was sitting
down teach them to the average person is
tough to believe during some what I'm
saying to that to the average person is
kind of tough to say give me a break you
had nobody that kind of worked with you
it's kind of tough to believe that would
you say that's kind of him
on its kind of you on how you came about
learning martial arts the way you have
I'm curious because Lana to say
summertime hmm so there was a great
philosopher in ancient China so he's
trying to explain right now
I don't really know his English name but
in Korean it's called mo Chou Salatin
that was mm-hmm and what he said is that
you know without going outside if you
look out the window you can you can see
the outside without actually stepping
outside in the bayonet on the veteran go
Joe go pocket I saw Oh
cheeto Graziano today and I saw coach on
WIC Taryn mamita so what he's trying to
say that the answer is within you you
don't have to go out and seek out you
know help or education if you have it in
you and if you can find it then it'll
come out naturally so boom boom boom
boom gotta turn into pupae Daniel boomer
all took it Palestinian to the mecca
named Joe single language hmm so in
terms of speed when he's fighting he
didn't think about speed you know he
didn't think about I'm gonna learn how
to be fast he was thinking about the
internal mechanism of speed and that
that's how we achieved the speed without
you know seeking out I'm gonna I'm gonna
do this and I'm gonna get faster mmm
because this speed is out of control it
is out of control
yeah speed is out of control so let me
ask you what is the method to pull
things out of your spirit like to dig
deep like the philosopher was saying
what is the method for somebody watching
the scene I want to figure out how to do
it what is the process of going there
and pulling that out so it's all about
training the mind the consciousness they
luckily Lucia Lucia come with me King
Solomon job CEO and it ties into you
combine that with the physical so
training the mind and the consciousness
and getting rid of unnecessary tension
in your body
mundo boom girl kiss on the mundo
pollinating he would benefit you so if
you wanna you know fill your water cup
that's for
then you must empty out the water cup
first right mmm okay so cuckoo park is
economy that case we give a Boeing case
oh you wanna hug me on
junctional we shouldn't carry you on the
Han Solo okay so keep giving didn't so
you're kind of approaching this deeper
state of mind as he calls it so you're
continuing to relax the tension in your
body tension in your mindset and slowly
kind of becoming that person very
interesting so let me ask you I when I
was looking at a lot of these martial
arts a lot of the topic of death was
coming up you know the topic of dying
like you know one of the biggest enemies
of a martial artist is somebody who
fears death how does you know from all
the eastern and western philosophy that
you've studied in eastern and western
religion that you've studied how do you
view death yourself young Turkish
evangelist don't Angelina do talking
going on
Qigong you 800 total answer me that I
was in a meeting so there's you know
differences between eastern and western
philosophies but he what he believes is
that there is an afterlife there is life
after this life so are you afraid of
dying like is there a fear of dying got
all for you or no no not at all okay so
does that do you think most people who
are fearing dying they prevent the
chances of pulling out the best out of
them you know what I'm saying like you
know how he's talking about the fact
that you have to figure out a way to
that person's inside of you got to pull
that person out what do you think
prevents the average person from finding
that person with the no gun Christian
they're gonna use again hey got a we she
gets meter so he's gonna define
consciousness as he knows it and there's
three levels to it you Patala - and it's
like the ocean mental edema won't you
give it attitude so the ocean is one
entity essentially but it moves
differently depending on how deep you go
culture music santero Almeida so what he
calls the first level is you know rough
stay or the surface stay and that deals
with this like the surface of the ocean
where there's waves crashing
you know all kinds of stuff happening
don't conjunct there's a Shekinah to
turn up to know us human and conjunct
the rear so you can tell is you so
there's you know different emotions
involved with how calm a person is when
it comes to their consciousness good
then what are you like a diamond on
which all social diagram I saw Oh Music
Video Music Center they're like a Tomita
so with training with mental training
what happens is that you you're going
deeper than the surface state where a
lot of things are happening in the
surface but less things are happening in
terms of you know water current and
things that you can actually see you
sometime do six Antigua Mita and that's
the some cut subconscious level these
until you look here you think this at
all to reverse Alexia but that's still
not enough you can even go deeper with
that IMG give me on this interior and
there's no current whatsoever no
movement whatsoever you gotta keep
pulling taro Hermida can you do a query
local hotels full mana come doing it's
all oh hello mr. English and that's the
deeper state of mind and when you
achieve that you're comfortable in any
type of situation it doesn't outside
does not affect your internals okay yeah
could they are the Padres you guys
Demeter and you can you can just accept
things as it comes without you know like
using your resources to accept something
meaning meaning like a mental capacity
of it let's say like someone is hostile
to you you just accept it without you
know getting angry at the person or like
what I'm gonna do what am I gonna do if
this person is gonna hit me or something
so okay Joel questionnaire yeah should I
get a minute yes Antigone you know you
keep pulling theater away the milk away
or truly just feeling good about did he
go to Marina to Noah treat why you don't
where they're so good young fellow
Christine says I could endure the part I
didn't you took Ethan take it so you
could Dominica so what he's trying to
say is that for most people they can't
even get to the second level it's all
the surface
it's all about the surface so without
getting to the deeper state of mind it's
it's almost impossible to bring that out
in yourself so it's not so it all ties
into fearing death or you know fearing
whatever but it's it's train the mind so
that you can you can get to a point
where it doesn't matter to you
do you fear anything Anand you know
nothing yeah so I would care to send you
a very funny story
check out the butcher got a stone the
you mangy mob an imbecilic attracted to
tabata sale so when he started becoming
famous and popular you know obviously
there is jealousy towards him from other
martial artists mhm
so then o Yanna Sengoku yo and Panchito
you've ever conduct austere sodomy cop
jamie anneka take any man in Santa -
Rebecca - so he was kind of on his own
he didn't have like a great master and
you know great you know background that
backs him up so when he got famous a lot
of people were pretty jealous mr. Bator
yesterday could you turn it on my shirt
this cyka come targets what is she
aggressive check out my Aikido quit that
way that you will so when he did a
seminar in Germany what happened is that
these jealous groups kind of put in a
false alarm to the police that he was
travelling with guns and drugs mm-hmm
good it's all save me a little dinghy
come to do see so while he was doing the
seminar the police came and took him
away
hmm send me another Tom's you gotta cool
good the retort a poison yeah he got
arrested I said really yes but you had
nothing on you
you had no weapons or nothing on nothing
you you're in Berlin on a few weeks
though you going back to German in a few
weeks right are you not going to Germany
he's got some travel to vertical yeah
okay next month yeah next one he's in
Berlin yes yeah I know you're scheduled
to go back oh good good I will come
doing absolutely so when when that
happened when he got arrested he was
still himself there was nothing that
bothered him it's all there was no fear
mmm Katya gets through that I just Amy
Alan - you go no no
- one goes out it goes even attacking
the Gupta hmm so when he told the police
is that I still have a job to do here
I gotta do the seminar for these people
so you can arrest me after I'm done so
what he said the signal Takanawa cleared
up and when the seminar was over he you
know he went with the police you know
what happened mmm a hotel is all check
up on entities you go your qualities you
go Mukul come sorry hon Tommy can you
cannot see me you know so he had nothing
on him it was just you know false alarms
so they did some tests and they you know
they searched his room searched his bag
and pretty much let him go I wasn't too
sure yogi it did when they Kalitta
Johnny
so he's trying to describe his
consciousness level so he's not fazed by
those things so he's he's at the deeper
state of mind and in turn that gives him
kind of like this mental armor is that
common in South Korea or no no it's not
yes yeah I know so could Koreans would
bad tempers by the way so good friends
but but let me ask you
politics in South Korea is it is it as
divisive as it is in America or notes a
little bit more civil yes of course it's
very different very it is very divisive
they'll calling each other out he's
lying this person is doing this he
cannot is it like that as tension as
here I mean you can even there's like
videos of like centers and you know
going out it's just like going and
arresting - essentially yeah I've seen
some of those are pretty entertaining
videos for you when you say you don't
fear anything at what point was it when
you realize you don't fear anything
Oh chocolate tiger he turned I see
bullion doing in Jeju she sudo no hitaka
couldn't get engaged she born in
Virginia so it's about 2015 or just five
years ago oh wow so it's recent so it's
not how did that have what caused you to
not have any fears in 2000 that's just
five years ago you're 35 years old
we should get I'm gonna talk okay indeed
require or come get Amanda so Mingo to
know we're seeing up to Manchester
observer could we sugar bun just
research on the way can they can check
out what I say mmm
so you know I can you know physically
touch your thoughts or it's like
right but while he was training he got
to a point where he can you know just to
sit he can physically feel what his
consciousness meant him and what it is
in itself so he recognized it and that
in turn kind of gave him this ability to
to not fear anything when that happened
in that state what was your immediate
reaction because there's an author
called I believe his name is David
Schwartz maybe it's not David sure who's
the guy that wrote power versus force
all Hawkins since David Hawkins David
Schwartz is a magical thinking big so he
talks about in this book power versus
force that runners experienced this when
they're running and there's a breaking
point you hit and then you go past it
and eventually you feel like a higher
power spirit is with you was it that
kind of a sublime experience you had
that felt spiritual where you all the
fear eliminated so what what kind of got
him to that point okay you get a little
movement gonna make engine stops in my
case okay say you are the hot tub woman
on would you go on the Singhania could
we should go to kiss you guys say okay
you guys I'm gonna get this hey gan
gagan and then Chris hit on Gator on the
don't they they go bite down on it on
the white are running over takayasu
bison burger cousin T so he pulls
interrogate a man on their Bunga they
were gonna haha go you go she or Britt
Condor is formed in Gautama
they got condors in it Hawaii Emily told
you done got the key so basically I said
cool it didn't cool take a harness you
don't you don't even think you so it's
it's hard to explain right I'm actually
really curious it's a mental training
and and it's all in his methods is WCS
methods but it's it's it's like you were
saying yeah it's like runner's high
pretty much you you set a goal and you
set out to achieve it and that's
essentially what happened to put it
simply and the three levels of
consciousness became like something real
for him it wasn't like like a goal
anymore it's it's he like he felt it as
it came
what happened at that moment when it
came like what did he do what what did
he when he felt it what did he do did he
step away from training and just have an
emotional breakdown like what was what
what was that moment like the boom and
logical can you Kanakadurga ninja turn
again to pick Captain Canuck and akeem
akio who you were or chanseong ironical
Thank You cheeky they would endure
Anakin gratis a video first turn the day
we should get bunch of cabin crew we
should get that I saw boom girl gonna
tarragon during gravity because a heat
rash on your own and then general
secretary military man each ship Union
you a Kuno together with us at a
Eternity key to grow on and you may
desire necesita you can see tyrannical
Roku
chicken who should pause in seminar huh
boom diggity wide you could you be there
first the bunch of kinda cool wish she
get that I saw de calcul or boot Aravind
Aravind guru they can jettison so before
this happened so as this was happening
he said he kind of saw like a bright
light and felt his body kind of fill up
with energy and he realized that he was
talking about his book is be there first
it's it's it's what he's describing is
that his mind is already there and it's
already been set for him and 2015 was a
turning point where that consciousness
just became real it became something
powerful that he knew that he can
achieve all these goals you know fifty
seminars worldwide
pretty much became world famous in the
martial arts world in a martial arts one
so prior to 2015
did he have a lot of fears and anxiety
and if yes what were they yes of course
what were they were just immediate don't
go anymore Tommy young go well your
daughter G Satsuma Quran go tell the
total making year so do you wonder how
go you honorable you on the hand and saw
Jessica the georgakas are you gonna go
to Oh Georgie Georgie so are you getting
with hmm so just like an average show
you no concerns about the future what's
gonna happen if I lose a fight what's
gonna happen tomorrow and it it didn't
just all of a sudden go away there was
like a you know it was declining
declining declining and 2015 was kind of
like the turning point where you
realized that all of that was gone
weight lifted off his shoulders exactly
a sense of
did you feel free like yes and and you
started enjoying life more mmm tire
chuckle chuckling yes sir of course
so chili sugar hands on a pipe cool
condoms okay go go get a bunch of kaiser
could they carry Babu
mm-hmm so do you know he's always
positive he's always happy and when he
sets a goal he doesn't set it to achieve
it he knows that he's gonna achieve it
mm-hmm you automatically know it's gonna
happen
mm-hmm would you say you trust yourself
today more than ever before
yes of course and that gives you
confidence yes is in touching Gulman
shenyang yes so trust higher confidence
higher if I have trusted myself fired my
confidence is higher based on what
you're saying you-you-you studied
Eastern and Western philosophy yes
what did you learn from both of them
what did you take away from Eastern what
did you take away from Western I thought
we enter I think you can do Cambodia
Mita in the company ago
so entering duly jokey-joke can two
young children got together Chung so can
they keep capable team at Abdullah
tokeijikaku who is a Changmin
eco-centric Athenian 227 atlanta duly to
veto the song track a duelist don't go
to enter a key pillar to memory scimitar
so with Eastern philosophies what
happens is that it could be very broad
and not as logical as you want it to be
like the western philosophies so it
takes a long time to kind of grasp a
concept in an Eastern philosophy so what
he did was kind of taking the logical
process of the Western philosophy and
and you know the East the broadness of
the Eastern philosophy and kind of
combine them together who did he study
the most on the eastern and western who
did you study for lost philosophy first
and it will go to religion okay
he said something earlier that sounded
like Socrates I'm just curious on who he
studied he definitely studies okay so
obvious he said it you didn't say it I
want to make sure he said that so who
did you study we are cutting in the boot
is awful do it there's a kooky demoniac
we're cuz I mean the sort of cutting go
into the Kadokawa soccer test you know
to get your annua
I know you said religion next but he
essentially studied Buddha and the
eastern philosophy but and
Western philosophy it was you know
Socrates and Jesus good even the choking
bundu the Candy Man compressor and he
extensively studied in the religious
aspect extensively really so you read
the Bible you read all you let you read
all the books yes yes Wow interesting
you know I always say if I wasn't a
Christian I be Buddhist because to me
the reading when you read more of it
it's just so deep and you have to read
it like four or five six times and then
when it clicks it's kind of like I can't
believe what this means if this is what
this means
that's pretty deeper feeling so you said
he said what he said Jesus Socrates
Buddha and then who else was it it was
one other than one other day you said
who do I think those are okay yeah what
did you take away from Socrates would
you take away from Jesus and would you
take away from Buddha are you telling
you don't key again he drove across to
me that Socrates to the broker Bluto
berroco Jesus to the Krakow time you're
learning all the shitty abloomnova cos
Hong it does to kuntala so in explaining
you know all three of them it really
depends on the time period and you know
it's like the social structure but
otsuma cuz it occurs to me that whatever
inna put a total ayat in there mm-hmm
but what they're trying to say is pretty
much the same you need to get into that
deeper state of mind to achieve anything
Oh turkey isn't it - no guys in money I
seen again soon oh no no you don't you
don't took an attitude about something I
saw no target to tell you how to manage
our territories I didn't eat you
Kukui talking echo Bhutan in doing muna
attack returning echo she just you know
she just seemed nine thousand a gecko
Socrates Socrates saying that sa you get
yaku a book talking hot cocoa candle you
can gonna keep punishing sanctity
Russell hanged or go singer how cool
orchid showcases her mythology so what
he's trying to say is that you know
Buddha grew up in India Jesus was you
know in the Middle East and Socrates
ancient Greek yes so they all had their
cultures cultural input into what they
were studying but essentially what they
were striving for is exactly the same
and it does not come from you know
studying the language
in reading a book or anything you can
only experience that once you get to
that that deeper state of mind a certain
level of enlightenment is that kind of
what he's referencing okay
let me ask you you you said you have
read that you also train South Korea's
police and military yes do you train
them yourself so how often are they
training with you is it a regular thing
what's the regiment look like I'm not
either so he doesn't really do it
anymore but he did it for three years
2012 13 and 14
- 12 13 14 in training got it
is the South Korea police and military
big into martial arts like is it a part
of regimen because I know I believe
Israel defense Israel's military is now
in Krav Maga I think that's what their
training is South Korea big on teaching
martial art and if yes which one is it
is there a certain one that they teach
the most and I mean the total amount
cool in the world five percent so he's
saying you know the martial arts aspect
of it maybe five percent because yeah no
I agree I'm just saying like some Israel
is starting to get into some of the you
know you look at the they said the five
countries and martial arts is China at
the top I think it's Korea then it's
Japan then it's Brazil then it's Israel
the top five countries in martial arts
and it's interesting why these countries
put so much emphasis in it whether it's
for discipline because you're not really
gonna fight somebody it's like why
today's all up there or through the
internet you're you're using systems
your cyber words more than the actual
fight you know how much of teaching
martial arts do you think is mental
versus actual physical skills all right
we'll deal with you five facets or five
hands to God oh [ __ ] there was even
there fifty harem dude you don't give
out to me that too much it I detail and
give you the cool auto sorry sugar Lupin
day boo Neutrogena go back will Auto
sorrow we should open the movie tours in
ceramics a the Eagle balanced armatures
unit so there's individual differences
you know everyone's born different way
you know some people might have you know
higher consciousness but their physical
doesn't follow some people might have
you know really athletic gifted body but
their conscious loved ones listen it's
all about keeping the balance um oh I'm
both huh interesting okay you know I
don't know why I remember when Bruce Lee
film first came to us and it was
starting to teach as Ajit condole he was
teaching he was his own form of art that
he was teaching and his folks from the
country didn't like that he was doing
that there was some controversy behind
it why does it seem to be a controversy
is it almost political when somebody
wants to come and teach and share their
style where some people don't like is
there some of that in martial arts I'm
curious to know what it'll say to that
settle he was talking about the fact
that he had some people that were
jealous and weren't happy about him
teaching what he's teaching is that a
pretty common thing that happens in
martial arts yes Sonia Kashuk Rhonda 38
Nakara could master culture master you
don't go with the kitchen she'll get
them in their cooker it's a puzzle and I
think the world hasn't gonna continue
again
so there's heavy emphasis on what type
of master you have and what type of
style that you train and so if you
deviate from you know either one of
those there is a heavy backlash why go
just culture that's a cultural thing
okay so is it a form of insult like do
they think you're insulting them like
are you insulting the culture and
heritage well kind of an apple okay yeah
okay that makes sense yeah because it
seemed like like Bruce Lee is trying to
train and they're like hey what are you
doing you don't go and share this up
with the Americans you don't go and
share your stuff with other people and
today you know everything is open so you
can pretty much show your style on
YouTube it could get 10 million views
and everyone's kind of seeing what
you're doing okay so you know some of
the things that I read that you trained
kung fu is what you trained well is that
wushu and judo what else have you
trained what different arts have you
trained yourself comfy okay and then
judo yep
posting boxing kickboxing kickboxing
okay Chinese oriental martial arts so
Chico Chacon yes Qigong Chico okay
McCrea tayo yes yes those are the words
and they all gonna go go or creams I
could touch in a planarian deterrence
everybody - also the kuda racing
so that's formerly what he trained in
but he was able to meet a lot of masters
across the board and so they were
interacting and he was learning from
them so so have you I'm gonna ask and
I'm curious know what you say have you
trained Krav Maga Krav Maga no or no no
no okay judo of course
Thai Kido Masters have you trained [ __ ]
wand oh yes
yes okay Aikido Japan you have it okay
karate you haven't trained cut it
assemble no Brazilian Jiu Jitsu no no
okay
and then Dutch kickboxing have you seen
you have trained us kickboxing okay and
then we tie from yes similarly okay this
each one of them have a different style
on how they do things in a minute I want
you to show it to us when we turn off
the camera and we go into what we're
doing but prior to doing that you know I
want to kind of get your take on a few
videos if you don't mind I want to kind
of say what you're saying about this if
we can turn on the video I was watching
Conor McGregor
yes it's fighting a seroma okay Cowboys
are wrong and they're fighting each
other and I think Sauron throws the
punch and he misses then Connor comes in
and then he does the shoulder three
times the moment I side I remember to
clip from you yesterday I saw you doing
it because you have this one thing that
you do with the pads which we'll do here
in a minute
yes and it seems pretty powerful and
then afterwards you see what happens to
his nose if you can kind of pull up this
clip so here's the fight he throws he
misses okay then boom one in the nose -
and he gets the third one it's pretty
much over but he can't see anything oh
my god
when you see that what are you thinking
like were you watching a fight LIBOR
Nelson you were watching a fight when
you saw that what was your reaction
yeah they tell you to get on Casilla so
he thought connor was really creative
created for him doing yes okay what art
trains that I've never seen that before
what form of our trains that conceal the
total well nothing going on
mmm honey kiss who did not go ahead and
go in the code routine there any main
duty king dodongo me I do notice how a
test is for a new module so in MMA he's
gonna get to it but the rules are pretty
broad like asunder by a code yet that is
very sick I don't choke up on kazoo
dicho cocoons auntie so would you go
punch a little bit of Kasaan I'm sure to
lose how long ago she'd go choke it
squirrel
so it depends on the distance that you
create from you and the opponent so
rather than punching with your fists and
that type of situation it's way easier
if we just strike with your shoulder
mm-hmm so call her maker you often you
in the quarry hey guys nothing about
here sorry about yesterday total so
telling to get on attachments and K so
you should order some gradual mm you're
not that lucky
it's not specific it's not an artifical
specific art but he thinks that Connor
properly figured this is the best way to
go to strike with my shoulder and that's
I mean that's crazy it's never have
never seen that before you know do you
think he was inspired by you to do that
or no you think maybe you saw it
somewhere else
yes yeah I think so you think he saw a
clip of yours to do this yeah I've never
seen that and and what I noticed a
difference you kind of come in when you
do it but he kind of went up you know
when he did it it was interesting the
angle he took because suros slightly
taller he went up and he went straight
on which was maybe he was using a little
bit of legs and reach and I don't know
what it was but that was pretty epic
when I saw that the angle Mari if you
can hit that one more time even the
first one let's just see the first one
on how he does it okay so if you look at
this it's about to come up the first one
he pushes up right he's almost going
like this hit the next one let him keep
going
and then he sees another opportunity
this one he goes straight because he's
lower and then he jumps up with the last
one as well
man that's a no-win how hard it this
feels how painful is it to get hit by
the shoulder is it is it sometimes more
painful than a punch I talked about it
in the conditioner doing the job so if
you get hit in the chin it's it's fatal
mm-hmm with the shoulder yes so fatal
you can kill somebody with the shoulder
Wow
well glad nothing happened here but that
looked pretty like a pretty intense
match right there can you pull up the
next one here's the next one I'm gonna
show Ryan Garcia I don't know if you
follow Ryan Garcia boxer he's coming up
he is part of Oscar De La Hoya's cam
that always one of my investors and you
know Ryan Garcia had a fight a few weeks
ago and they showed this clip I hope we
have it that it's next to each other on
how he's training and he's practicing
this punch over and over and then when
it comes into real life if you have it
press it I want him to want to see this
okay if you if you notice this one here
so they're fighting okay do you have the
other one or no so he throws a punch Oh
gone right can you go back to it again I
mean do it again go back one more time
so he's about to fonseca's throwing a
punch how fast do you have to be to have
the instincts to respond to that as a
guy who's taking the punch
no no I'm talking Ryan Garcia when you
watch this his eyes are not twitching
look at his eyes his eyes are still open
it's not like closing his eyes and
throwing a punch he knows exactly what
he's doing you can tell this guy's
trained this and thrown this punch
20,000 times to know exactly what to do
but I'm what I'm wondering how much it
this is speed how much of it is instinct
you tell pancha got a new lead and a
coupon to hug each other
Gary sure got so sanctimonious conrete
mo da língua
so before this attack happened this
connection happened what Brian Garcia
was able to do is figure out the
opponent's happens you just hung the
pellets evidence it they're regarded
Aragog we say so when the
his jabbing his guard is luring told me
some developed a cougar chuckling with
you
so he rang her she essentially kind of
trick the opponent he he basically
didn't show any sign that he recognized
his table that day that's crazy right
there
take what I did they don't go to Poetica
attacking a wall not in Korea to Kiko
castle castle coos come on gee that'd be
something great so what happened is that
Ryan Garcia was just waiting even this
to happen so he recognized this habit
that the opponent had which is no and he
just wait for the right moment and the
right distance to deliver that blow
Kutaragi I pay you keep them with it so
come get someone ganglia mmm so it's not
just you know the momentary instinct or
speed but it that was planned out is
what he said that was plenty she was
hungry pennant want to adjust the
eruption in Canada one you look at or
Chile's gonna go it's an opening opening
it's a you know crucial habit that he
was able to pick out from his opponent
but he didn't you know he didn't show
any sign that he knew that so he just
waited waited and planned this blowout
that's that's pretty intense what do you
want do you follow boxing and MMA or do
you watch it yes watch you watch MMA and
who do you like in boxing who do you
like in MMA maybe the hug or maybe they
can ditch wahoo so he loves for I'm a
mother really
and don't make really just jr. Roy Jones
jr. I was on a flight with them two
weeks ago and interesting why Mayweather
why Roy joined poisonous hang is a Jeff
word I'll go straight to DA go multiple
arrests and we're go for the book she
gonna stairs hold on one dozenn current
there could there a book single change
in Ozone you so the common misconception
when you think about boxing is that you
you're just using your arms but when you
see Mayweather Roy Jones then utilize
their entire body and that's what's
attractive tone good okay smile hug a
soldier and they're they're smart
fighters Roy Jones and Mayweather
you think they have similar styles or no
there's different styles because Roy
Jones had a power plant Roy Jones knock
people out Mayweather is not a knockout
artist right he's more in a more
creative artist the way he fights
complete different style of fights yes
would you drink can it really that's
different different five different stuff
okay but you like both of them who else
who do you like in MMA and mixed martial
arts Conor McGregor you like Conor
McGregor
would you like to train with him one day
yeah would you like to turn out if let
you stage one because if he sees this
yes of course
yeah it'd be very interesting scene you
guys trained because I would want to
watch to see what would happen if you
guys drink because I like his style the
way he fights it's like he's a very he's
got this unpredictable yet he's quick
and he's fast and he's got the power
behind it and psychologically you know
from the moment he came in it seems like
he knows how to control his rage today I
don't know if you're noticing that if
you can ask him that question because he
did an interview and originally he was a
very big promoter the way he would
promote fights I don't see him promoting
fights to where he promoted fights three
years ago he seems like he has come to
his own and he's actually become a
little bit calmer is he noticing that if
you can ask him yes of course you're
noticing that as well ladies getting
calm you think that's a strength of his
okay okay he me Tanya yes over Chris Oh
ginger akane tendo passing over here
cool cathodic King Chinese don't looking
go passing go out there so what are you
saying Conor McGregor is that he he's
becoming more and more creative and also
his mental game has elevated yeah how
dangerous is that how great is that
combination can give you much I mean
even then he's gonna beat we need you to
get you on time because I mean I wanna
come get pattern he took out in there
getting inside a moon captain Goree
ahsoka tano photographer wait a minute
your other team will get a [ __ ] we know
nothing with you hmm
so it's it's deadly in a fight because
if you're not creative then you almost
always kind of reveal a pattern to your
opponent right but if you're creative
that means you have all these you know
other types of weapons and Arsenal's and
you're under your belt watch him against
cubby did you watch the fight when they
fought could be yes I saw what do you
think about could be happy protesting
can create panini cauda equina go to
Thailand
comida Caponi met dr. Joe Cardin Pam
bubble salad
so he's the best at what he does so he
so I'm not talking about you know
striking game but the wrestling part of
it he he is his body is meant for that
and he is extremely talented and good at
it
is he beatable no because how how does
counter beat him Connor wants to fight
compete right how did Connors watching
right now let's just say Connors
watching right now
how does counter beat could be if they
face each other okay in my opinion
mm-hmm Vontae tokonoma credo go Xavier
lost on a column a Canadian dog thank
you
so what he thinks is that if there's a
rematch between them
he thinks Conor McGregor's gonna win you
think so why yeah top until a certain
economic regal happy by the end
younggu got some 20,000 a cogwheel to
result in by the young guru 20s all
sound Daniel could Cory to do a calendar
economic regime down socrata hmm so the
first fight that they had he thinks that
Connor didn't really have all the
information on khabib so he didn't
really figure out his game before he
went to the fight and when they fight
for the second time if he can play with
the distance and figure out the distance
and the timing Connor is probably gonna
win that fight similar to Diaz because
on the first time you fought vs he lost
did you watch him India's fight the
three fights with the earth yes he lost
the first one he won the second one yes
right two times yet different because
the second time Diaz was pulling him and
he wasn't going so Diaz wanted ground he
didn't go glass so do you think one of
the mistakes that Connor made is fall
for the ground game of khabib do you
think that's what it was
uh okay Joe was Tynan kono make really
to come because the Comanche choke we
know she took it to attracting oh man
each other how do you really give you
something taken on your Concetta he said
you know how do you truly walk them in
there like hey look to the part where
they get even a kiss or indicated you
create so can you catch alligator
paternity I think we know how do we
throw us the counter interest include on
didn't else irritated they cook it to
pursue Qatar coming
so what he thinks is that Connor might
have been under prepared in terms of
stamina and just playing the distance
game
the counter punches Connors pretty much
trademark yeah no doubt about it
so what do you thinks is that the
stamina part wasn't totally she wasn't
there yeah so that's why he got grabbed
and ultimately lost a fight any any
strategies you would give them outside
of that so the current strategy is
distance don't go too close I think
that's kind of what you're saying any
other moves anything else you would
suggest for Connor to exploit khabib
exploit key word is exploit it doesn't
take cage over again Xavier like I said
you put three dog walking around in the
castle to to do I determine a Koopa -
Johanna coos cordierite you and never
pugilist indigo do happy the true in the
class just ivan khorev and their crew
korean song me a young guru can see many
other about sonic emitter current a so
happy patrol new single account register
in the new girl or contains something I
guess it Tommy on Utah South Korean
cameo somehow he will you sup job
so he thinks distance is the only way
only way the only way yeah distance
creating the distance encountering is
what because khabib is that dangerous if
you get on the foreground with them
check on your car wrestling Johnny they
get their man
I should gentle yeah and so it's it's
very difficult to beat have you baddest
game that's great that's great no
believe me I mean III understand it but
it's good to hear that do you watch John
Jones or Anderson Silva fight yes what
do you think about what do you think
about John Jones or Anderson Silva don't
just kings and Cody attend conduct so
cool cuz I made dinner
I get sense looking duels having a
centimeter so what he thinks about John
shows he's got the distance figure out
and he's a striker Good King Day party
any job we do quite a good get them when
a party cannot I mean can say bar to get
together honey on cuz something's water
tagging subtle touch it throwing in Joe
Doyle and he is physically gifted he's
got long arms and legs so when when you
fight someone who doesn't have as long
arm is used to and or your legs is used
to it's very difficult to kind of go
through that the striking essentially
that the John Jones possesses you think
John Jones can lose because he's never
lost he lost one time because you know
when
first came he didn't know all the rules
and he cut a guy pretty much put a
massive scar in his but he's never lost
you think John Jones can be beat yes do
you think somebody can be John Jones so
in might have you know yeah you say no
say it's very difficult I agree yeah
because you watch this guy I mean the
only time you're gonna beat him is if
it's conditioning is not good and you go
like you last rounds with them because
he just seems out of control good
how about Anderson sila some call him
the greatest some say Anderson Silva may
be the greatest fighter what do you
think about his style you're so cool
Kadena credo should accordion timing and
a trial okay your song each wasn't a
Seoul Korea did you go tiny touches on I
was I think I can do Oh mommy so we we
keep going back to the distance thing
this is the most important
Wow three times I'm also and Ursula is
very flexible and he knows how to use
the tool said he's got the cheddar Gail
Coombs you can with castle castle now
you got to serve us in your attic good
mmm and as he ages the topic because it
becomes a stamina topic so as you age
your sister Kenyon can you keep up with
that movement that you're creating okay
let me ask you in the MMA world who is
Dean who's the most dangerous fighter in
the world that can beat anybody in MMA
not boxing in MMA who's the most
dangerous man in the world but he thinks
the heavyweights a heavy way yes okay so
so so you think size matters because you
know sometimes in martial arts a lot of
criticism martial arts gets is that they
don't think it's about size it's about
whoever's quicker
whoever's more strategic but you're
saying whoever is the bigger guy has the
advantage I'm curious
oh my god you got the talent Adubato
couldn't have them talking to them to
put each already given area know
Kentucky just couldn't go to check out
one candy candy book happy coups on
Sarah Wright two clips on surround sound
and here comes my any more candy oh [ __ ]
Union asking John is a sound
hmm so in like an MMA rural settings
basically if it's like a combat sport he
thinks heavyweights are gonna pretty
much out class anybody it's it's like
it's basic physics if you get into incor
accident with you know like a big Mack
truck then if you're in a mini then
you're not gonna survive that right but
you know to contract contrary to what
he's saying a lot of his a a lot of the
people in the martial arts community
would disagree with that and what he was
saying he followed up with it's
different if you're in a combat
situation where it's life or death or if
it's in a ring somewhere okay so if okay
fair enough then let's talk about if
it's in life or death who wins if you're
in the street yeah so so take John Jones
take on or take all these boxers
mayweather take Pacquiao take him in the
streets okay and put him with a master
Grand Master somebody in the martial
arts word that he has a lot of
experience it's no rules
who wins strength another man injured on
yo kongsuni you can double meter mm boo
Oh Bonjour Bonjour Terry nasarah Munjal
you know I get a bunch of tail inside a
museum I'm so curious what did you say
it's it's very difficult to say because
it's I mean life and death situation
doesn't really come that often right and
what are you saying he can be political
with asked about one of yours answer if
a real fight takes place who wins
I'm talking you face-off you got a
grandmaster guy that faces off one of
these john jones some of these guys this
person has got different abilities than
they do in a street brawl fight who wins
no rules good I get kinda rocket
Hopalong this is not politics out for
your US policy mmm
chicane German singer groanin Bonjour
Terry Miss Hannigan in their window
tennis at the beginning they get the
popsicle you do Jamaica yeah folks over
here Jenica so
what are you saying is that a whoever
gets the first strike is probably gonna
win in a in a streak bicycle okay I got
it
well when we're talking about like
different disciplines of martial arts he
think boxing probably has an upper hand
more than anything
oh my gosh like yeah his answers are so
weird because that's not what
grandmasters say you know when you watch
the interviews that's not what they say
why box think has the upper hand
Dunnan 201 documents I'll get a make a
call you got you we got the kid is a
South Dakota body Gilligan either I
don't go to Justin become cool Corey got
books articles are you doing good
tigey the difference' son in Korean
language are morally wrestling talk up a
pool or take on the total Mauricio
200 so frankly about this you gotta
stand and Koryak a cup chassis some
doom-doom new car cause you eat a minute
could on the boxing those are the color
didn't create you to the punch in
October
can they abolish them there so the boxer
speed and the distance in a street fight
scenario that's their game you know they
have the upper hand I got I got okay
that by the way just so you know a big
criticism is given to martial artists
like I'll bring this next one up for you
have you by the way Tyson what are your
thoughts on Mike Tyson Mike Tyson at his
best
Mike is amazing guy amazing us would you
say at his best he was the most
dangerous man in the world Mike Tyson at
his best
yes yes Cody is a good career so dig in
the heavy could be right to go to Rome
to get them in there so I screamed I
conjure up Joe
so Mike Tyson what he had was a movement
of a lightweight but he was a
heavyweight
did you watch Mike Tyson's the recent a
moment that he had what he said when I
was he got he got emotion I don't know
if you watched it or not what Mike Tyson
got emotional about how it was when he
was fighting it was a part of his life
when he lost it he felt like he did he
watch that ask him if you watched it at
all familiar like Vanna and Napoleon no
the more I read the more I eat the more
I know they ought to fight that no
thought of war that's what I was studied
that's what I'm Sophia that's what he
feared me when I was in the
because I thought my I was a knightly
that's all I was born for the other
things are gone it's empty I'm nothing
I'm working on spilling the art of
humbleness can you be that's reason why
I'm crying because I'm not that person
no more and I miss them
there's sometimes I feel like a [ __ ]
because I don't want I don't want that
person to come out he comes out he'll
it's coming with him and it's not funny
at all sound cool I'm a woman I gotta
tell you get the little you should cook
a woman son take radio can you create
them you know we shouldn't kings imagine
and the kaboom critical Paulo - good
Casa de moto run and Susie so get a
manicure girl apparently my Shulman
there customer to sing it too good and
so boom clean do London day we shouldn't
have starting with you great then we
could we should cut the accreditor
--boom ye boom son tasted terrible you
just aren't a critic accredit them and
there can get easy man Lucy Kiku boom
control what time we got to Manta
jingles ah so you know the name of his
mentor customer I heard him say cuts yes
I'm trying to understand in math when
when he was around he was able to
balance that physical and the mental
but when he was gone when he went away
his physical game just kept increasing
but the mental was increasing decreasing
so there was a big distance so he his
mind couldn't control his body basically
is what happened how do you I mean for a
guy to say that how much did you will
study Tyson like he was really study
Tyson to be able to say something like
that which exam taken over a hotel room
a little esoteric ago they ain't never
gonna cheat anywhere Jessica so suddenly
can take Highness had taken Johanna who
and girl Coco the catechu Isha gazpacho
longer go in the canoe she country they
mana
kukuku she won't even go not just right
we should get trainee and English mm-hmm
so he didn't really extensively study
Tyson but he can just tell you know how
the example that he was he was saying is
that there's certain songs that kind of
remind you of the pass and that kind of
matches up so whenever he gets into that
fight
you know that that emotion will come out
but as as the balance are breaking down
it just it just became haywire
Tyson yeah Tyson and I agree obviously
when cuts when cus was gone everything
was gone
for him it's similar to what happens
with the movie rocky similar story with
what he called it with Mickey when
Mickey dad I don't know in the movie
when Mickey dies it's a similar scene do
you think most people experience that
when they have somebody that especially
if they had a rough life like Tyson who
had somebody that comes and becomes the
father figure and gives them that hope
and they leave how do you replace that
confidence with that person that leaves
your life plus sometimes you rely on a
person that brings your confidence what
happens when this person dies and leaves
how do you still maintain that
confidence lasted I said customer
tolerance of a mythology we could
balance it anomalously mature and and a
Tyson you made us all Camilla song a
song says front it I put hard good
morning boys Jesse Mika the Caruso
dinner all cheering she sang it in with
the custom of Solomon is very similar
control circuit you we're gonna come
mentalize it inward so you need a mentor
basically is what he's saying cuz as he
got more famous and more famous all
these other interests are coming in
right you know someone might have bad
intentions and he kind of became you
were sacrificed basically what happened
so you you need that mentor and with my
advice yeah that fog father figure that
can lose that in his life so Matt Daniel
sale in a daze okay so single call go to
touch it at a so young guru hello or
cookie so America blue dog would you
just do so it's not really any living
person so he takes his cues from like
Jesus God are you saying okay so so the
next one I want to ask you is the
following if you play this next clip
this is with I believe it's Julia donger
against Qin Jia Wang you know that the
the names are known you don't know the
names no okay before you play let me
explain to what this is before he played
so a there's this debate between this
MMA fighter in China who says any of the
martial art stuff is fair
it's not as effective as they claim it
is so he calls out a grandmaster the
grandmasters chair yeah Wang and maybe
I'm not saying it right but I have the
channel when we can put the spelling so
they can see what it is mhm and he faces
off against this other guy who is not a
martial art he's an MMA he's purely an
MMA and boxing and they fight against
each other and this is what happens I
want you to watch this
so grandmaster against MMA Taiji
grandmaster against MMA what do you
think about that that's acceptable
thought so Chinese martial artists say
that you need to go sit so he knew from
just by looking at the way they're
standing he knew that the Chinese
martial arts master would loose why it's
a tricky little pair so his center of
gravity is too too high too tall
they sound like this yes MMA su casa de
coria tiga I observe mmm so he doesn't
really understand the distance thing
when the my father is inching closer to
him Oregon tomorrow district Westerner
Kubuntu I gotta choke on a scimitar so
there's three factors associated with
practicing martial arts Cody hey Danny
it's your understanding and distance
good I'm a tiny and timing and the
rhythm hmm conduct Korea I got tiny I'll
read to me I hope see but Chinese
martial martial artists does not have
any of those the Grandmaster be honest
now by the way they asked him the guy
that beat him the MMA guy to publicly
china government asked him to publicly
apologize to embarrassing
the Grandmaster because they didn't like
this they frown upon his to the point
where the guy was thinking about
even China and going Australia because
again it's this levels but I love his
answer it's the levels to say you know
these Grand Master's tight she had the
ability to do certain thing because you
know what do they call it you've heard
about the Bushido have you heard about
[ __ ] Oh have you heard of anything
with [ __ ] or no okay I'm okay so
[ __ ] oh is you know these guys who
they put their hands on you and you fall
and these guys who know how to do
certain things and it falls so you see a
lot of guys posting these videos Dana
White posted or Joe Rogan posters
sometimes and you see this videos that
looks fake martial art and some of these
MMA guys are just calling it out
how does she follow any of that stuff or
what does he think about that fake yeah
okay you get the little Cody about
timing a reason when water to Martin and
sounded the [ __ ] mm damn it so he he's
saying that those are fakes
oh he is also saying that yeah you know
what I gotta take this
I think for people who don't know who he
is
they didn't know your views this is very
good to know this stuff because I don't
know if you most people think that he
would support them or he would support
some of these thinkers some of these
philosophies and not say if it's a fight
that we're gonna have he didn't say Tai
Chi's gonna win or such-and-such go he
just said boxing is gonna win if we get
into a street fight with no rules right
his answers were not the answers of what
a lot of these grandmasters give I kind
of like the way he was taking the
approach and I think he gained a level
of credibility because he's not here
promoting and self promoting and art
that's bigger than the other one out of
curiosity if you were to get into MMA
today if Dana White gave you a contract
and you're going to fight tomorrow in
MMA let's just say do you think you
could Hank and fight with some of the
other guys like you watching a sad thing
I can beat that guy do you think about
that oh cool okay you get on there okay
anyway so to do and we made it to a
geometer
y seguir so cotton candy Choki Choki
mussolini you know Sarah we are and they
kind of highlight our inverter turned on
take in you go drink some of the eyelid
you know roll tape and some type of
failure anyway supposed to do a fight or
something but you can they I mean money
efficient so can get tuned
- [ __ ] roll special materials Argentina
hoministe' color like Rihanna yeah
sometimes here in the condom you could I
forget you
yeah so what are you saying is you know
first of all he respects all MMA
fighters and you know what they're doing
for the industry and everything but when
it comes down to if UFC or Dana White's
willing to come up with the fight you
know that hasn't enthused audiences he
can he's saying that he can fight
anybody he think you so you think you
can fight anybody you're that crazy
pointed him out but do you think you can
fight anybody and go up against it
doesn't matter and and you're not afraid
you would do it so so busy almost shot
gonna oh yes of course
I didn't operate really free yeah okay
then you know because I would be
actually curious I would I would want to
be curious much you know how they did to
set up with Mayweather against Conor and
there was a boxing that took place did
you watch mayweather encounter Boggs did
you expect Mayweather to win like did
you say may where there's gonna be Conor
unboxing of course you knew that because
of distance or because of what because
of speed or what what was it because
they both understand distance and they
both have a punch
Rudy you tell me I could do the cha-cha
anything go so maybe it maybe it a Rudy
so that's what it taught us all Coco no
maker economically my son and there may
be other take Julian you read them an
economic rigor but that may be the
Washington is Hollywood hmm so the rules
saying it was highly advantaged for for
Mayweather because he's been doing that
for years and years and that's
essentially it
he just had the upper hand and if it was
a street fight who would win when I get
kicked good as a song than Aikido Cody
so miss Howe Tyson engaging in oh maybe
the Judy huh get you when the thing is
her meeting with them there so in terms
of understanding of the distance he
thinks Mayweather has an upper hand even
in a street fighter ii fight even in a
street fight
that's not a lot of experts say a lot of
experts would say Conor but ok that's
that's good you know would you mind we
started doing some stuff here so we can
watch you in action while we get into
doing some stuff here so so I figured
instead of
asking all these questions why don't we
get right into it and look a lot of
people wanted to volunteer but nobody
was more excited about volunteering for
this then obviously our you know our
very own Mario Aguilar Mario Aguilar in
the past got punched in the face by you
who was it Chuck Liddell so we figured
if we have the MMA guy that punches are
maybe it's a good idea to experience the
the the fierce puncher of a martial
artist and then at the same time we're
gonna go through a few different things
maybe we'll test how to protect yourself
against the knife to kick your speed and
you can kind of walk us through what
you're doing so I'll turn it over to you
so right now this is the one we're
talking about with the yes I'm sure how
to use my shirt so like this are the
strike and the Gyrich punch so I don't
have these turns I don't push a little
hit this pot like this how much should
that is legs how much that is shoulder
how much is your euro hips
ah so when you punch in is it legs as it
hips or is it shoulder so let me show
you like this it's better yeah so my
power will come from the ground em knee
and paribus spine and feast so it's the
whole but the same together at the same
time you're turning at the same time to
say yes well don't push or litter they
hit I did Wow okay how about the one you
do with your shoulder how do you how do
you how are you doing a facial same
technique so just to try to use horrible
like this got it when when Connor did it
the Connor go
when they kind of go straight can you
show the difference yes of course Oh
take a [ __ ] diamond
Dana Dana go Joe the connemara gonna
kick ass and I'm gonna talk it they when
they're you don't worry also chinko me
so it depends on the heart of your
opponent if they're tall naturally
you're gonna have to hit upward if
they're I know smaller than you you're
gonna hit downward mm-hmm and then the
church again I'm gonna Sunday Sunday
toggle you didn't get it always aim for
your opponent's chin in the day Sunday
Bonita bono cool Oh chin da man to grow
Arab over cheering cushion dog Laika
cutting it mmm so yeah he just showed
you a sequence you hit first with the
shoulder but you reconnect with the
other elbow and that's more effective
Yelp was more effective than the
shoulder yes church in death of me
elbow room government way on the same
side yes since young distance but not
this elbow you're talking about this and
this is how much I eat sugar so I think
you okay God come on
got it so it depends on the situation
have you ever used that in a fight
Ksenia yes many many yes so you have
you've used that in a real fight and
what's happened to the opponent knocked
out gone
yes just the one what is your most
effective punch or most effective way
you attack your opponent yours most
powerful jaws you win because I'm
creature Dabangg a corded it up hostage
a coded modulation a queer cuz I'm a
just hungry banku or some time again
just tired opponent mojo okay du pere
ubu Edo period
cuz I'm touching and taken even boy yeah
yeah part in winter so it doesn't really
matter but it's all about striking first
so it depends on the situation depends
on the opponent depends on the distance
that you create but it's not any one
technique but if there is like certain
techniques that you want to see heat
using I sure - yeah I'd love to see him
you show it to us basically yeah
yeah some demo we sit there or chatted
on Egypt Iran they're really looking
English so you don't get into like a
form or anything it's just natural like
that sometime I through menu so when you
get closer to them come pardon my
language and you just strike first
right can you do that one more time yeah
can you do that one more time yes so get
closer Mario Parul do noodle something
about Kenyatta so he goes for the eyes
hmm
you go for the eyes first yes okay
mm-hmm okay how about kicks mm-hmm
kicking your window to cut here some
dabangg it true as they're just complete
power song they won yay cotton Buddha
chillin good mmm
so you strike the nearest point of your
opponent you can they you get something
on the top hit you you're not like how
cold you get choked so if you miss then
you risk the opponent grabbing you
mm-hmm good good you look good honey
much that's when you utilize kind of
like the short distant work with your
elbows with your shoulder those
components come in when the distance is
shorter in the boredom whom you're going
to impact together ideal and he's
talking about the so-called impacts and
every strike needs to have this impact
Oh
Teddy Teddy Teddy Teddy broke oh sorry
just crap please
I also turn off state oh cool so much on
the impact another language so that's
that's the impact that he's talking
about it's not you you're not really
pushing your opponent but it's it's that
short impact that you give I think Mike
Tyson said it best your shoulder snap
that's the same thing yeah why are you
breathing hard is it
are you are you pulling from here when
you're punching are you breathing out
what's your breathing when you're when
you're punching it doesn't matter
oh it doesn't matter yes what do you
mean with doesn't matter oh the whole be
she needs to get on there because of you
on some painting wood because opponents
untain language ah so he's got to come
to a point where he's not thinking about
his breath anymore it's it's consistent
throughout mmm got it you're not even
thinking about it at all no okay so what
what are three common mistakes you see
happening in fights in a street fight so
a guy he goes to a bar
what are three mistakes people make in
fights that they don't know what they're
doing and what's the immediate easiest
reaction to it when I was shipping up to
the sámi producer Karaman crickets
around recut song just Romani honest I
gotcha
Cody a 10-year gentleman Joe time will
turn down in game integer hmm so it ties
back into the distance thing that most
people don't understand how to gauge
this job on you know keytar away sort a
check on dieter can we sit long beauties
here so let's say you got into an
altercation blooming beauty today is not
really doing anything Sunday but it is
cool cup take a table of the panel
important to do so when when the
opponent strikes your grabs you then you
can't really react to it if you're gonna
naturally you know nonchalant about it
because the solemn is hung top saw me
money apology get in that meal crew
Korea and they saw Kim Dae Kim jong-kook
Kim jong-in up on Indiana should be
thanking Django Joe cha he's on T so
sanctify Otto que todo para la gasolina
is Peter Quinn angry Jimmy language so
it's like a midpoint between complete
relaxation and tension so you're not
completely tensed up but you're in the
moment so you're you're ready to react
is what he's saying mmm-hmm career then
Kingdom the me up she could young he
relaxes on till we let some this little
tongue so if you're just kind of natural
about it you're like whatever then you
can risk getting knocked out oh so he's
saying position and be ready be ready
what what's a good ready position
what's a good ready position a street
fight done the talking Gilman isn't it
already but position II that for him
that's he's ready there that's you're
ready yes for you
yes for me crystal Santa Bonnie isn't a
thought or attending the parking go has
two guys here so let's say you're gonna
attack him yes and here a strike comes
right away here Parrinello Roger Kitumba
don't appear to be doomed I'll insult a
soul great please
so there's no like preparation phase
he's just react like it was a piranha
gonna go sir
when I get min Damiano so the pocket of
Parana language
part of that long so it's it's just
immediate there's there's no difference
what you do he's gonna find a way to
counter it and the most effective way
possible Kapoor Ronit in Goa I'm Jenna
kitsch
chomp-chomp a static gentleman don't
know so it's like a loaded gun
pretty much so you're always ready to
fire but it's as your entire philosophy
counter is it all counter-attack sorry
may count on you
okay mangia count Tony on evensong going
mean you are more counter to me Shannon
yeah I'm good yes yes very good tiny but
well no I'm not asking timing what I'm
trying to ask him is you know like if
I'm fighting you and I'm coming and I'm
playing offense I'm coming at you right
it's his philosophy you're fighting
waiting for you to move first
I move second Oh Monica I gonna get
stoned double bond bondic i getcha
so he's philosophy is in striking first
oh she's breaking yes yes in the bowel
I'm moco connect autonomy cadet key
there in the capital minute okay so it's
there's a difference between what his
mindset is so if he's ready to fight
then he's gonna strike first but let's
say he's not sure so sure
then he it's it's like a reaction from
that huh what do mean he's not so sure
so let's say he's not totally into the
fight he's not I'm ready to fight right
now so when he's in that mode he will
strike first but let's say it's
circumstance to right is where you know
the opponent can attack you first right
then it's a counter but when he gets
into the fight mode the combat mode then
he's always gonna try to strike first
why oh you Tannen begum Ando Teddy
Nagiko don't cut amudha jr. we couldn't
Monica's Hyundai my activity told you
get them in a good town can give her she
showed you so when you strike first and
you're able to hit your opponent you
know that's gonna decrease their
potential of attacks or they're just
going to decrease their or you say their
capacity for attacks so he's he's
attacking first to essentially shut the
next attack off pretty much so it's not
it's not a method of shock factor to the
other person it's just not the other
person to get a chance to think about
their their next move computer so you're
trying to instill fear and yes fear yeah
got it
you go to boom in them
sparring Honda to Katya it's the same
thing in a sparring situation for sure
spar you know it's the song that
Japanese Japanese Iraqi descent America
if they don't clean the powder again how
much talk about hey junior could him in
a comforter Kato
hmm so even in a sparring situation he
will do those jabs to make him fearful
to make him react slower due to the due
to the fear you don't you put it okay
yeah um Ptolemy doughnut Adam glue trap
mmm so that's the priest step it's it's
all about a mental at first it's
instilling that fear and then going in
for the finish interesting so you go
attack mode to put the fear in them so
let me ask you does it vary based on
sport or no meaning is it different from
boxing than MMA an opponent or is it
just a philosophy period with your
boxing or it's MMA look at you oh yeah
well someday banget doesn't allege again
tomorrow they work on taking your
Congress on them at the computer to
indicate to me there in a minute
they Sunday buy any computer cable now
because I'm Akira Charnock Timoney so
technical aspect can vary but the core
principle is is instilling that fear so
that they can react as fast as they want
very interesting because it's it's
almost like thinking in sports a defense
or office right he's on offense mode the
entire time got it
okay very interesting how about kicks
how about kicks on you know basic except
seen you throw the low kicks to keep the
distance I've seen the side kicks you
want to kind of put the shin guards to
see what that looks like
yes don't relax yes yes do you feel it
[Laughter]
yes so de vino' stayed on that reading
me up she without walking go even
walking on the Trianon ingria so this is
gonna come out naturally as he walks
he's not gonna do any crazy jumps
anything like that this so that's me yes
so interesting so you walked in you
didn't even do anything
and then bull the consultation with you
so you're increasing that acceleration
at the last minute someday by stearic
academically put your I see Jessica the
Sunday biopsy to rule not get hustled
maji maji
impact too much English so you're almost
silent you get to the point of striking
you're almost silent or to get to the
point of striking okay Scott what else
what are the form of kick yes so side to
keep espera yes yes what's more power
that will decide the side okay yes more
yes Becky so you did one you did low one
you did low right here then you did the
walk where you just came in and you did
to me and then you just did the one now
what else is there okay Joe
it took you my golden which overturning
key to me say so he's gonna kick a
little bit higher no yes yes we to
Brittani khadija up to lieutenant kicked
on impose you mean so she also you to
throw language so it's gonna look like
he's coming from this side but I it's
actually come from this side I mean so
language to himself
quick mmm got it
how many how many of these can be used
also in a real MMA fight you know how
many of it is is everything you're
teaching practical enough where it can
be used in a fight or is it more part of
the yards so kickball down and boom
intelligent that's a committer got
cousin under Jaco in the kisser let's
all check out a little aggression in a
moment Eric you got a minute
cool all right Keith retire plops hmm
from ie kisses how are seen them II
guess we'll do bro cool chicken keone
Kela Roku remote IO hadn't gotten you
can use 100% of them but it
what's more important than technique is
your your state of mind in the body what
does that mean so you can elevate your
technique game if the mind the body is
already there so it's all about
cultivating the physical and the mind
more more than the technique because
they they will follow if you if you just
kiss you don't and I would on the moment
okay came and anyway I'll take it
speedily the cue go I'll take a powder
de Kooning 120 mm it's all about using
the entire body and just kind of letting
your body get to the body and mind get
to the point more than trying to learn a
certain technique is this gonna be
effective is this gonna be effective if
you if you get to that point it doesn't
matter which technique you use it's all
about using your body
utilizing the best way that you can
optimization so once you show us
different arts like you know the
difference between judo difference
between conch food difference between
you know once you show some of the
different arts and explain each one of
them so your the supporting cutting
young winner
read the meter cadet Joe this is boxing
show the boxing in the book sure you
will Tai Chi captain Young winner Tai
Chi Chi Chi return Buddhism and the
traitors having a song a gig in Bermuda
mmm it's all by using the entire body in
Tai Chi Chi Guru tells you to you on the
job teaching in you utilizing your whole
body oh come on man
oh you don't know wrestling I'm gonna
put you live in you know what total I'm
not beautiful Jessica it's judo or
wrestling try to push him to Sandow
second bit of us here to push him with
all your might come on Maurice got legs
you can't do it Marius so you tip the
balance don't get beat up yeah guys like
pushing on the wall which one is pulling
there's one that's pulling this conch
pullin which one is pulling okay guru
Don given conductor on bovine yo thank
you
Oh Wing Chun each oh it's ring Chinese
water mmm so you know the result okay
I'm on it tasted a good thing you're so
chillin good you're pulling yes so then
give me a saw
not good so you strike as you pull you
strike your you pull out you strike you
or you strike as you pull this little
boy simultaneously okay so when you're
doing that you're punching and pulling
at the same time yes okay I got it I got
it
how about Jeet Kune Do what's what's
what it what's that what form is it I
don't know you don't at all
yes okay yeah got it you didn't study
that all yes okay what else what other
form what other thing that you study I
don't know
Auto Start button and boom interior
thought initiative me what the MU meson
kadian go to position say I think it's
hard so he doesn't want to talk about
like different disciplines cuz he he
wanted he wants talk about the state of
the body so he can show you how to
utilize his body meaning leverage does
he mean by leverage or how to use your
own body weight so it's gonna tie back
to the whole his philosophy why don't
you just let him demonstrate yeah you do
something at equality so don't go to
jail but on the deal so it's it's gonna
be a jab dad you don't know Kim Jong
some test on college a beer and the
first one is striking the tension
jabbing with tension
oh how can there you gonna look okay you
want some kids honey Tiberium and that's
that's a relaxed state daiquiri Sheraton
go in then you wanna support to go
through Gasol has a conjunctive cuz home
Jackie conjunct the Sun case hungry
mmm-hmm so let's let's go back to Ryan
Garcia can just not it's like in between
relaxation and tension well there's a
very discrete tension is what is
describing you know Kim D Gingrich tiny
no pool no he's a pot in the English so
that was the price never I understand
who's demonstrating the 22 time ago job
utilizing the entire body okay like this
what you say mm-hmm if there's anything
else yeah so anything else who wants a
show yeah you don't get you here it was
all jab you chillin there sank a ballot
engine her finger they were chillin girl
finger they were chillin there
she also Taurasi see it was all check
out she get a meal something boy look at
my power I get you
power to Japan please yes right they
Crimea
yeah okay so look at today I any bikini
much hmm so he he's gonna quickly change
the direction so he's gonna give the
illusion that it's gonna come from the
outside but it's actually gonna come
from the inside Kukoc we're you to get
the chill over a minute at the pet spray
i you to catch it so much course yes and
so that's not technique that just comes
natural
so so you're not a take that you're not
it so so how much of what you do what
you teach would you say is natural
instinct and how much of it is technique
how much of his natural versus technique
chose a hide-a-key wheel tire yeah
critical quarry that a sammich indignant
Corita sadhana kisser carcinogen so
first he would teach them how to use
utilize their entire body and depending
on the distance
that's where different techniques come
in mm-hmm so you know like a short
distance you maybe elbow and shoulders
and and a further distance more punching
and kicking
mm-hm he's on peaceful deal Oh turkey
City ops II tip Iraqis julieopp
shido-san about a dashiki
talk about a slice it so without any
specific technique he can strike the
opponent and he's gonna sure it right
now then the Chinese over selling good
and he's being creative mhm
hung them on at the technical bougie
girl so he's gonna show and this is just
for show he's gonna show that this is
coming mmm talking about the puja could
go back would you know he switches that
so it's a big part of your philosophy
illusion
oh conditioning would and he says it's
very important Dabangg end up with the
Dunagan doctor I'm in Oakland Tara take
it you but if if you know that you're
better than the other person you don't
need to use the old got it emotion it's
only needed if you're facing somebody
your own level yeah exactly
I that's very interesting what he said
he's so so meaning and I'm gonna say to
see if I'm saying saying the right you
don't need to use illusion against
somebody that's not at your level you
only need illusion if you're facing
somebody that's above you that kind of
what he's saying yep or like the same
level or same level now did that make
sense yeah it's very interesting you
know to go up against somebody that's
bigger than you so go back to the kabhi
begins Connor okay
would he use illusion or know if he's
Connor oh yeah yeah Cody to choosing go
to the hunting lodge Oh God Kaname
career guide okay just our job Cody
little USS Samuel The Hobbit Tolkien
Amica can we cook Auriga
I just home Jackie Tyler Claire you
don't know what torment rokoko you don't
do and Rococo kuqali retorted but that's
what a pathetic hassle
Hanan gotta a career in korrasami so
he's gonna create the illusion of you
know he's letting you attack with the
distance and with fighters it's very
discreet it can be like an inch of
difference and that makes all the
difference so he's gonna keep his Connor
then he's gonna keep going in and out
giving that illusion that I'm giving you
the distance to attack before he attacks
good hobby with the pandeiro cookery a
saw or took it a little yoga tell you
I'll forget you and hobby would you know
his strategy would be if you're in my
distance I'm gonna go in right mmm-hmm
criminal Habibi pudding do Oh Teddy
honey so troll economical mmm-hmm happy
would use also use of the illusion
that's right mister triking and then he
goes down and picks them up and gets the
legs and it's over cuz that's what he
wants because they don't yes I'm sorry
go ahead
yeah they don't know Gohan Goku painting
a bit that I do
so as you create the illusion that's
what the striking comes so the illusion
doesn't last the whole way it's you just
subtle give that appearance and then you
strike yes whose
better at the illusion game could be
more Connor Canoga which hasn't any
manual single akia so their first fight
I don't think Connor did a very good job
I create illusion
Nikki bundleco negotiate I see Joe Cody
to cook or eat a potato two potato top
Atari Castle counter Cheney Canyon but
overall Connors tactics and distance I
think he's better thank you
in illusion yeah it's just specific in
the illusion side yes I mean illusion is
just a word right but the gauging that
distance is also kind of an illusion I
guess but it's also the very you know
tactical position it's a strategy
did you watch Maas Vidal's fight did you
watch maas without when he knocked out
I think it's been he knocked out with
the knee in eight seconds did you watch
that master I'm a badass
no oh you don't want you to yes you know
what can you play that let's play that
well think I want him to see it bread is
in the building and these guys just
slapping gums at each other any chance
my clock is brought to
yes one more time please Ren also on
hand game bread is in the building
he's just flapping gums at eachother
[Applause]
spongeable
so the why been astron lost because of
his habits mm-hmm
squint a little hello we're certainly
Joe he went down when Maas vlog came
charging and then cuz Ben Askren is a
restful is his downfall and mas Badal
knew he was gonna do that lieutenant who
you shaggy come Johnson tail the moon
Louis here and there too excited I think
Ben Askren was too hyped up mm-hmm can I
say kinda but listen did you get open
the lot guess what cool they had a beef
what are you saying is that you know it
seems like they were angry they really
wanted to see the end of this fight mmm
and that's why he lost that he followed
this fight at all or no no so you know
you didn't know this fight at all that
took place
oh it's pretty interesting because
everything he said he's right yeah well
what happened this fight
uh how about punches let's see some
punches so you thought she was having is
a tiger Hanna come on Joe he a boarder
throwing is a choice you Taylor nobody
cares so he's gonna do that elbow first
and it's all about utilizing your entire
body same principle jaw isn't a soul
choice you think so Kyle comida yes
that's the starting position and he's
gonna so both feet move or one moves so
one more oh okay you're both so you're
going you're standing you're going boom
boom aiyah both okay you got it yes
you don't know what together some
dabangg eatable drew us please how much
in English
so that's you would use that when
someone comes and grab you I got it
okay somebody comes in to grab you yeah
using that great please
okay the first dude was their language
so fast first okay to the chin yes
oh you got the macho give me the tag in
there Charlie she was having a soul
can't get her mojo same principle entire
body strike you feel that yeah there you
go no Oh chica me human t-butyl true or
loving will to the shimmer Paco soup I
see
so the impact it kind of carried on high
but he can he can change the course of
that action so what you're gonna feel
next is its par gonna come more downward
towards your stomach like this yeah okay
I got it
angles yeah so you can move you look up
quick right straight yeah so something
in the kitchen why stay
can you feel yes can I ask you can you
teach him how to become a better puncher
so why don't you go over here you do you
throw a punch so he can I'm serious he's
stand over here no no no you throw a
punch here oh you throw a punch here and
you tell hey I see a storm wise how to
get better cartooning with a car guy
watches form no humor peg-wheel so you
want to relax he's gonna teach you yeah
so will as SS and you can imagine the
your arms are like a stick the from here
to here yes yeah like I see it's like a
firm thing that doesn't really move you
when you hit you can imagine to using
your take the Ferger to here and then
throw and the connect from here to here
like the stick like stick and then just
a throw
he's not even same punching just intro
yes yes you like that we throw so yes so
you're going to be doing go wheel you
pushed a little bit mm-hmm so Tom just
impacted tons of a idea palette on
geological go so tailgate kaoru trillion
dollar economy so it's like an arrow
going through a target it's not so much
pushing but it's like that sudden
acceleration and the impact that makes
it so don't think about punching here
maybe think about punching your boss
that's pretty good it's a better better
it's mirror and you feel a different by
the way yes yes yes yeah very good very
interesting yeah yeah very interesting
what else would punch in what else would
punch in should people be thinking about
Garden choice you design is high
overhead wheel buddy Mike impact okay
integer yarmulke so the whole body thing
is really important but also the impact
is really really important mhm so that's
that's just physics right when you're
throwing the punch in your generator
throw the punch yes
what is tense is this tense no sir
laughs nothing is yes last moment last a
moment and task what we're we're worse
I'll show you less yeah this time at the
end you're yes last moment wow so it
small timing what boy why why do you do
that way castle totally give it over
here to increase the acceleration to
increase the net seller Asian yoga salt
or evening with you let me ask you a
question can we get that on slow-motion
when he throws the punch okay let's
let's do that I baked you cookies no one
we will show this on the screen okay
yeah well but now do a full punch will
slow down you throw a full punch screen
on speaker yeah
so you got tense at the last second yes
let me show you this time this time
you're coming up you're coming from here
so the typical fighter that fights you
know street fight they typically go out
right and that leaves an opening for you
you're more worried about how fast you
can come in yes come on dear whoa wait a
minute
forget children good stance so you don't
want to create a big movement you always
want to kind of think about going
straight the shortest distance possible
that's crazy so in a street fight a
guy's fighting yes he's gonna come like
this when he's coming like this you
you're opened up right there it's great
yes coming straight yes yes he's on
Pierce also straight - okay economical
gweal a poco de tarragona milk
finger jab tak Navajo polish on you good
luck it in with so if you open up then
you're gonna get you're gonna get risk
you're risking getting hit pretty much
so you're not a power puncher guy like a
big none of you're not big on that
that's not part of your game no it's not
at all
so it's who gets their fans there is his
game
yep interesting got it it's very good to
know can we see some stuff on this if we
bring them out here for you to do some
movements I don't call you do is hang on
and Grail it's a corridor so I could get
on with the come kiss hurry up so he's
gonna show you like the short distant
work mm-hmm
so ah yeah you don't get that in again
you know it okay dating English ah sorry
gesturing okay okay turn you know you
again so they didn't same thing
utilizing your whole body and creating
the short attacks the short distant
attacks how many times did you hit him
right now yeah so of course yeah bone
hmm maybe a part-time yes like this what
is that - what is that doing are you is
it a form of a punch because what is
this doing here yeah what is this doing
here
yes is a throw like a time when a
character echoed a troll angry Sancta
one-sided rocket a moon a also Ted in
Canada is interpreted in wood so it's
all about where you position yourself
and the distance that you create so it
doesn't matter where you hit like your
entire body is pretty much a weapon at
that point so it's it's all about
positioning yourself and just fear now
what's the most effective way to get
this guy down do you really yes yes sir
so he's anticipating something van Gogh
tomoco me no sir product yes
what are you hearing though what are you
hitting yeah here okay got it
just hit do you wanna feel the punch
with a boxing glove cuz you got it from
Chuck sure yeah let's go get the big
boxing gloves and he hits you with the
big ones right yeah I'm just curious to
know like yeah fourteen ounce that's
what we have you I wanted my other uh
how do you defend against that we rely
on Canada you can't
yes Kent oh really like a gun same okay
but you have to get in those so you have
to you have to get in to be able to do
that right so isn't it kind of because
what you just showed right now you have
to be really close to do it if the game
is distance and you're coming in and I
throw the kick or I'm throwing a counter
how do you get in Cody Rhodes hydro
peanut oh yeah you got okie girl punched
oh honey oh good Corey wrote a GOP know
whenever I don't come over how do you
get some quality contained repairs are
you gonna do Cordia school code really
keep them in there to go Maurice it
didn't create a teacher so that attack
only comes when you're in that distance
so when he's in this system he's gonna
probably utilize kicks or more than
anything else yes yes so Molly Molly is
a tenor Cunha canter I get paid in words
let me ask you do you watch Nick Diaz
you watch Nick Diaz fight you know the
book the Diaz Nick an atheist yes yes
they slap are you are you is that a form
of martial so you believe in a slapping
part yes okay so we're not gonna do face
one you feel that and then you decide
because you tell us okay
yes it's better Tess oh yeah tense okay
yes yeah yes okay yes [ __ ] he would not
do you feel it really really so Paul do
me a favor uh grab them grab the camera
go grab the camera not the face go grab
his camera Mario go grab his camera and
let him hit your shoulder yes okay okay
are you really okay Paul let's see it
ingeras comedy I want to take one
example what it feels that cuz I want to
know dude and he's hit in the shoulder
it's not it's not yeah so just turn
front pants
yes yes okay okay oh yeah if you ask
somebody else it really yeah yeah yeah
somebody did when you mean beep what do
you mean be like oh yeah he me Castle I
told his drawing oh yeah so the force
transfers inside so it's all about the
impact that you create right can you
punch like so the last moment impact
yeah poor guy man
yeah Bob didn't do anything but you're
gonna be all right buddy
and good news is you didn't feel it
because you're a dummy okay Wow so the
impact yeah huh no we're not doing the
head but when you're when you're doing
that can you can you do that in slow
motion I just want to see your feet on
what you're doing with you with yeah
yeah Rachel your knee rotate to my
pelvis and through my arm
our last moment the hit okay so let me
ask you first movement is fall on so
stand straight and straight before you
punch just answer it before mine okay
what's the first thing that moves the
one and two and three and four so it's
four yeah first it goes one two three
four
yes okay I got it so can you not do it
in a fast good doing and doing it fast
yes write this like this like this got
it I'm just looking at you're like yes
so this is this is form I have you see
it's form because this you're putting as
your foundation there you have this is
the one that's moving yes and coming in
yes that's a stable move tell me about
pulling you do a lot of pulling pulling
is a big part of your game
why why do you pull like cars like a car
accident make sense I get it yeah I
notice he does that and he comes in here
so you know in a regular fight can you
do that in a regular fight this does it
give you two openings because if I'm
fighting you know if I come like this
I'm potentially opening here yes or no
yes okay so there's a little risk so I
have to be quick to be able to do it
distance called util good Cody is an
outstanding academic a Cody - cool
in what so here punch me once I want to
see what it feels like yes punch me once
crunch yeah okay want to feel oh oh wow
you know it's crazy you feel the bone
yes exactly you you feel the bones it's
not even like go let me let me see this
yes is not mm-hmm that's a very impact
yeah yes you'll do bones you you don't
even feel yes you're fair yeah you don't
even feel oh you don't even feel well oh
yeah do it again
mm-hmm you know you don't feel the glove
mm-hmm go yeah you feel that yes
you feel that's a piercing pain mmm I'm
gonna bruise up tonight yeah that was
solid body now was solid if you were to
say if you were to say where your power
mostly comes from God would you say leg
hip yeah or this where does most power
come from
cuz I'm couldn't even all these annoying
ground ground yes meaning meaning this
yeah pushing yeah pushing the ground
this put this dead leg is yeah share
pushing the ground hello Tate and go
so is it almost better to come up a
little bit I will come this way it
almost seems like if I'm coming up it
gives me more power right grandma and
young Vito changes in your [ __ ] tuning
in on Yanni my video can you shake so
it's it almost happened simultaneous so
yeah can you shake on rotate and move a
little bit up where at the same time
mm-hmm
so your start position is where where's
your start position yes the push and
rotate and go impact didn't I put it on
a state autocut here Oh Bonnie died for
the pitocin dedication in there Tony
Duquette up John code it'll get up where
so the way he holds his knife is a
little bit different from everybody to
that's that's how he holds it that's how
you okay so can you generally give you
said you know category and then Kim
general huh get this all cutter you
don't cook it you can suck it in and
that you don't care that we're not each
other's out what I say
so the first approach in your tensed up
and your knife just kind of becomes it's
like an obstacle almost so you kind of
tilt the knife and relax your wrist go
get tension each ok because I would
intentionally up Jeff so with the first
approach there's tension in your wrists
but with the second approach there's
minimal tension you got to look at their
finally shaken a boom totally mature and
it's all about the explosion of speed
with the knife fight as well mm-hmm so
the sanctimony OMG in the quest to
compress party nominee no matter how
dumb gene so as soon as you move he's
gonna react to it mm-hmm
yes I go to check out how much insanity
are Colossae and that and he talked to
the special forces in Korea that
what they learn in Special Forces
bayonets bayonets yeah
with knives or bayonets because in the
Army we use bayonets to get ahead you
okay I got it
mhm I got it interesting okay you're
letting your ninja yoga teacher OH
san giovanni de queretaro stay humble
the jelly jelly Oaxaca Damian Angelica
days here so there's a precondition to
this if you're trying to not get stabbed
then that's probably not gonna work so
you're you're thinking I'm probably an
established once if the if you're in a
situation where someone has a knife on
you oh you have to be prepared to know
that you're gonna get stabbed one yeah
at least once okay the cousins animal
man it's also the car essentially woman
me cell phone huh boo let me - hum - I
quail so like right here that's a knife
scar he's got a knife in his hand on his
back from a fight yeah someone Wi-Fi a
real knife on the street Sunday Bonnie
carrot rose Hotel Sangamon queretaro
state day or boomerang get absurd no
code there's something about Karabakh a
children go to mmm so you're not trying
to do anything you're just kind of
gauging it you're engaging the distance
and you're not reacting because you
you're gonna risk getting stabbed or
slashed mm-hmm hunga Bunga cutter the
Chum the good part along with you and
you want to remove that out of that line
of attack and then you go in so it's all
about that speed that's the speed is a
factor look at them when they can - gulp
Joe so there's no guard because you got
a knife on you
so once she gets that knife out of the
way it's really easy for him to connect
the attacks so kind of go part of an
angry make sense goal number one is
eliminate the night then attack okay
well why is he saying you've good you've
got to be prepared you're gonna get
stabbed once go away mindset behind that
my incessant agility I know how that
woman will become to take evasive
jellies Daniel you gotta let me come get
there even Santes condoning go to relax
the santalune Santer so silencer ki-moon
do you seek a mundane go meter so it's
kind of freeing your body of tension if
you're trying not to get stabbed you're
not
they're gonna tense up or you're gonna
try to do something to avoid the knife
attack
so that mindset is I know it's pretty
extreme but you know you want that
relaxation that that midpoint between
complete tension everything is the
interesting insight you know to say that
be prepared to get stabbed once that in
your mind takes pressure off because you
know you're gonna get stabbed don't just
get over it and move on to the next
thing that you need to be doing exactly
huh you get that right that's very
interesting
it's a form of anticipation expect some
pain it's gonna be tough but you can
overcome it
very similar principles to everything
else you doing business someone you're
gonna create an enemy it's okay but you
can still overcome it I like that to
people at stake so the cha cha guru qu
yang go cha cha cha guru no cocoons on
the Raimondo can google hangouts on the
mountain angry so you create a strategy
if there's multiple people right so you
always attack the person that's the
closest to you you always attack the
person closest to you mm-hmm
okay got it so you're not picking the
bigger guy or the smaller guy you're
attacking the closest guy yeah CJ Cree
yeah
the couny say autonomy on some debunking
debunking in their chosen by a
connoisseur yeah could've been something
wrong and I'm not a greedy kim jong it
is my hockey team yeah so the first
track is always important so if you
knock the guy out with the first strike
then you know the other crowd is gonna
get this one one and then they're gonna
have that fear and then what's the
what's the most people you fought with
cut down balance around songs street
fight ah kill illegal Myung hyemi oh
yeah seven to ten yeah seven to ten yeah
see in China and you got all of them yes
but did they know who you were yes
Russian yeah no oh they know who yes to
the street on the street and they saw
you
yes seven eight ten guys and you beat
all of them up mm-hmm currently recently
yes a knife
so this that's unfair yes that's from
that fight because they had a nasty and
this T what caused the fight
we're sámi dollars the channel gets
heavier in Chicago in then there can you
come over how much money it was like an
armed robbery okay and and you how old
were you at the time
yes I was 2007 27 years old okay long
time long time ago but back then you
were still good good
engine and could you give me running dos
okay so the young guru hug ways at a
joke video so you know how you know that
epiphany came in 2015 yeah but the thing
is that he's always been really good at
martial arts always since what age on
Jarrett okay alright so since he was a
very young kid so he is in Korea he's
very well known within the martial arts
community he's really good no I think we
know that we we could weave contact yeah
okay that's good that's very good to
know have have people knowing who you
were other grandmasters or other
fighters know martial arts Jewish
religion movement I'm Jewish because II
guess I'm just too close you go kaboom
go mommy hot chili desert there cuz then
I'm a pianist and a cousin amy hanen
Goga teramachi gonna come to no salomina
and he's haven't got to give me to
cutting mojo touching the big animal so
it's it's quite universal across across
the board because he he has students
that are like politicians
you know doctors businessmen
entrepreneurs in South Korea they're not
coming in to learn martial arts they're
coming in to coming to them to learn the
mindset and the balance between the
physical and the mind
and simply creating the optimal
environment for self growth and self
development so through self development
you can kind of elevate your game in
anything that you do so he's not
focusing just on the martial arts it's
it's about oh it's a way of life so you
can you know apply that into your
business principles if you're big
self-help guy is your big business book
reader if you read a lot of books he
reads a lot of books
okay can you ask him what are some of
his favorite books I'm not talking Jesus
or Buddha or Socrates I'm talking any
modern day people books that he reads
Vivekananda Lama Rama Krishna I check
out my patio chickeny can do a church a
teacher in doing it that's like the
Indian I don't know how to pronounce it
yeah I know who he is I know he's
talking about yeah you said Robin Sharma
yes yeah yeah I know you were talking
about yeah interesting so you you it's
most of the stuff you read on breathing
meditation and your mental state or do
you read business books and self-help Oh
petunia Chicago hospital my people will
hadami hmm in the trick to the
magnetometer in magic there a lot of
ancient texts he reads mm-hmm so you get
closer Delina curtain go to my nipple
boil like ancient Chinese texts you like
so like something like our art of war
like what Confucius or who you really
are
war is a big one okay yeah I mean that's
like a given there I figured very cool
if you want to bring the nunchucks real
quick forward to seeing what he could do
with that I don't need I don't use oh
you don't use yes oh so that's not your
art okay very cool were any of your
street fights do people pick on you or
were most of them accidental they don't
know who you were a challenger so he
actually went and found in the street oh
you went in it yes why was he white did
you have an ego like were you like a
more ego guy and you wanted to beat
people up or were you trying to get
better
economy Sonya Allen this hello kiss the
moon girls don't go to candy toys at the
haruka saw what said o Kesava said okay
so about that urging no yet in the cross
Kotoko clean sound much waiting with you
so he just likes to fight let me tell
you i'd love to see him fight like a
name I'd love to see him fight somebody
and we actually watch it on TV to see
who he fights uh I'd love to see you
what are you way by the way you 165 170
what's your wait no
so Pesci acutal 80 kilos 176 I was off
by 6 pounds okay so you weigh 176 okay
that's a good weight it's a lot of good
people to find out 176 you know I'd be
interesting to see if somebody reaches
out so you got you got two books here
it's the same book obviously this is the
one in Korean and this is the one in
English what's in this book I'll tell
you got to like a man intellectually
they only title I say how about a touch
it the English so it's like a
culmination of like different philosophy
studies that he's learn over the years
and it's like a melting pot those
concepts that you know he thought he
found it true in itself and that it
could help other people God you guys
here we go into a hisagi cook a context
hash it equal so you know through our
lives there's objective views and
subjective views right you take a look
at them in their could they borrow me or
took it that book is I go to get
haciendo Chaka Khan CK do the Creator
Suman on or tricked out that I will turn
you into reggae literature so this book
kind of Lau's you to look at yourself
look at your life emotions goals
everything in an objective point of view
so that you can kind of pick out what's
good for you and what's bad for you and
like I said earlier it's a culmination
of different philosophies and ancient
texts something that is learned along
the way
chapters names are pretty casting aside
interpretations only the mind is
changeable discarding old habits
ultimate goal of decay understandings I
am fear analytical psychology human mind
and behavior at the beginning of knowing
light and shadow
true meaning of good fortune
transcending the body free will power of
stopping the heat of the will facts and
interpretations very very deep I mean
somebody's chest is a pretty deep
chapters you got here and you also got a
website right there's also website that
you have that people can go to find you
we're gonna put we're gonna put both
links below both for his book which you
can go order and we'll also put the link
for his website and social media if you
want to go message him because you're
honest to grab your active on Instagram
he's very responsive on Instagram yes if
you want I mean that's essentially how
that connected to them I just emailed
them cold I don't think I want to come
three years ago
yeah but brother thank you so much
coming up and she was amazing appreciate
you for also helping out with this we're
gonna leave all the links below for you
to find out more of dku who came out
here to be a guest take everybody you're
not was glad i was able to do the
interview dku was telling me this is the
first interview he's ever done in the US
with anybody so this is a way for a lot
of the folks in america that we've seen
him on youtube or facebook on all these
viral videos with him doing his
movements to get an idea about how he
thinks and i was i was myself surprised
by some of the answers he gave and how
authentic he was being and he says luck
nunchucks i just don't know how to use
him he was being very open and
transparent i want to hear your thoughts
which you took away from today's
interview click below and comment below
and if you haven't watched my interview
with Chuck Liddell some tells me if you
like this interview
you're also gonna like the interview
with Chuck Liddell so click over here to
watch that interview and again if you
haven't subscribed to the channel please
do so thanks for watching everybody take
care bye-bye
you